bonjour je m'appelle lucas j'ai 24 ans
et aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer
comment gagner plus de 20000 euros par
jour dans un jeu vidéo uniquement par
contre haut de gamme studio c'est un jeu
dans lequel on monte un cam studio voilà
maintenant et parce que ces gens n'ont
absolument rien à [ __ ] et je ne sais
pas en déduire par le nombre de poitrine
convoi juste dans les écrans de
chargement et d'accueil de ce [ __ ] de
jeu on va employer des filles pour
gagner de l'argent parmi ces filles là
qu'elle attire son attention tiffany
[ __ ] ou qui an'a ya une fille qui est
fine
il ya une fille qui a des lunettes et
des gros seins il ya une latina qui a
des grosses fesses ça médias que les
points sur les i on va prendre le gros
cul latine
cette violence en plus y en a aucune qui
fument et qui boit ses splendides
elle va nous rapporter 1 dollar par
heure pour finalement attaqué des hommes
sur des sites de rencontres donc il faut
la prendre et la met en mode tu bosses
allegro qui faisons la faire un rapide
un skype quoi bon la prend et on la met
dans le studio insulte un juste à
cliquer sur le music pour gagner les
souks elle a généré 5 dollars à temps
pour une latina grosses fesses aux
seychelles ou skype on a besoin de fana
on va faire un shooting photo c'est
malin ça alors ok l'eau photo studio
d'ailleurs un shooting et du coup là on
collecte des fans ce génial
ok c'est parti là la meuf qui fait le
tuto battouta privé d'ailleurs pourquoi
tu fais pas ça elle même tenu à prendre
et débit elle préfère fortune alors toi
on va te faire travailler ensuite est-ce
qu'on peut pas avoir des nouvelles
filières non et pas moyen sous pour
acheter des filles c'est le très lourd
mais en fait c'est un simulateur de
mafieuses de jeu alors on a 12 fans du
gros cul et trois fans du genre latina
je vous comprends les mecs je comprends
alors en assaut et bélie uni qui met
lycée nazia tic chemische mais ça veut
dire flash est aux abois la femme aux
gros seins comme ça on a de tout c'est
très bien ça c'est très bien puis on
fera un excellent mafieux dois tu vas
aller travailler bordel là où il rien
faire et je la fais travailler comme un
[ __ ] alors zoé nadia l'aîné au yen il
fait des tatouages et le truc hyper
cibler je suis sûr que tu auras des fans
2000 fac tatouage alors faites-nous du
[ __ ] d'argent faites-nous de la thune
bordel de merde alors le net aux
boissons on va te faire voir plus de
fans en faisant un petit shooting photo
alors au niveau des fans
il adore surtout les gros cubes au bond
les lunettes à l'effet pervers bizarre
les 1000 20% et les gros seins 15%
seulement aujourd'hui plus on apprend
des choses c'est de l'argent allait
skype à skype est chauffé les mails
chauffer les mecs demander leurs vins à
l'opa gîte pour leur montrer votre doigt
moi je pense qu'on devrait ramener nadja
la mille fois non mais c'est vrai elle
va en faire une star mondiale va faire
plaindre à brunswick photo ça a cartonné
aptel d'une barre de stress les filles
et plus elles sont stressées plus il
faut les mettre au repos avec j'avoue
leur fait faire d'escale 24/24 quoi
notre à dornach et tous les mecs de
conques au point fr elle et toi tu vas
n'ose pas vas-y détente au spa ou leurs
pas
ça va quand même on est cool mon gars
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut s'acheter
alors attends faut les payer 30 de leur
butin les pêcheurs un âge avancé des
bénéfices de malades alors au niveau des
pronostics et on en est aux [ __ ]
l'habit fait passer devant les tatouages
le cul surtout en troisième position
bien je comprends plus rien mes goûts
sexuels des mecs savary comme les
couleurs c'est n'importe quoi
d'accord on peut envoyer des filles au
club de strip-tease elles gagnent les
pointes allant allez on va regretter le
fait qu'il sera une milf qui aura des
tatouages et tu auras des lunettes
laleu-la total ce sera notre poule aux
oeufs d'or alors bélisle au la zoé
hollow la [ __ ] elle est talentueuse
aller vite
ebony et bollène et du skill de ouf lola
pardon et boucles n'importe quoi on va
prendre l'eau la mecque lola tu va
remplacer le fameux lunettes et un
rapport tellement de fans elle mon gars
exceptionnel est là tu as 50 de fans
quoi [ __ ] elle trop de succès
incroyable là mais il faut admettre au
tricot strip tease toi on va te faire
faire un peu de shopping
castrés globe ces médias l'envoyé elle
et l'a 72 heures quoi elle fidèle à mes
plus beaux tellement aller retirer ses
vêtements c'est drôle ça on s'amuse
alors le cps a fait gagner des notes de
musique c'est parce que ces assisses ok
c'est du style à ses gènes maf âgées
lors encore plus de ce qu'il c'est super
on est montré un doigt pour 5 euros elle
montrera deux doigts comme ça au [ __ ]
tu l'as tu écoutes a gagné mouiller
assez incroyable d'accord devant fait
j'ai des filles qui boit avec itunes du
coup elle stresse moins mais des gazons
plus de clubs ou d'alcool est stress
comme des oufs donc faux j'en vois
quelqu'un allait acheter de l'alcool ou
des clopes table c'est super glauque
mais alors au niveau des fans sans nous
les pronostics fit m&f fit maintenant
bas comme elle voilà la pelouse de dents
ebony bas comme elle va la pelouse
d'orgue les 1000 falémé font tous un peu
de succès les tatouages atteint lui
aussi les gros culs et les gros seins
c'est toujours pas de successeur croit
alors à ce que j'ai de quoi vous payer
toujours pas je suis désolé désolé suis
un connard en plus elles sont toutes
très c1 comme nous alors on va tous vous
faire bosser un coût et avec les sous je
vais vous payez tout vous envoyons par
petit pas pour toi et toi et toi tu vas
faire des fans ils nous font les abonnés
que quand il se connecte faisait jeudi à
l'aube à sanofi les justes pour remettre
notre came alors comment tu du ski alpin
buissière qui dépasse on est des [ __ ]
d'esprit faut bien se mettre ça dans le
crâne jeu génial championnat diction
mais j'ai un peu le bâti cac 40 et qui
me demande à quoi joue ce jeu j'aurais
l'air hyper qu'on écoute jeunes lutins
de mafieux là y'a des mecs qui font des
sketches des payes un quart de ce que ça
me rapporte je suis un fils de [ __ ]
[ __ ] manqué de clopes et de et
d'alcool lazer chaud et vous êtes chauds
avoir à fumer ne voulais pas arrêter
c'est une perte d'argent et de temps
pour moi en tant que mafia s'il vous
plaît les filles je fais tout pour vous
je suis vert gentil et vous embêter les
couilles
ah merde j'en étais je suis à -58 si
j'ai la zone rouge plus de 24 heures je
vais je être viré mais non elle ferma
que tu me vient pas comme ça au général
la thune sinon le boss du team hommes
violés
c'est une petite fille de 6 ans car oui
mais bon c'est la maison
je suis dans le rouge deux il ya du sang
en fait le jeu permettent une c'est
quand je les envoie acheter des [ __ ]
que je peux pas envoyer un larbin jeter
des clubs plutôt qu'à nice et les stars
du site banc dès lors que va faire la
promo on va acheter cette femme et 21 et
23 ans on était comme des fils de [ __ ]
mon un max de fans on est mort pendant
des mois je me suis endetté comme une
merde on va faire un crédit s'il vous
plaît mais généreront jama c'est une
excuse pas on va durer pas dû recruter
trois fils des débuts ça va te tuer je
suis dans la merde si je suis toujours
en négatif
robot 24 heures je suis mort je suis
dans la merde partout quoi y'a plus d'al
khor il ya plus d'argent n'a plus rien
plus de passion il ya plus de passion
dans ce qu'on fait c'est ça qui nous
mène à la fin assez bon par contre que
la paix va tout mais ça va faire très
très mal j'ai toujours en négatif mais
quinze jours la mère d'un bonhomme je
m'en sors pas de l'argent fait de
l'argent au fait de l'argent demandaient
plus de allopass toujours plus haut la
tête tu es plus en plus grosses bêtes
justement dans la merde je crois que
c'est la fin d'un business plus tard en
train de trahir mais là le crédit leurs
pensions jamais à temps et qui en plus
d'un prix un taux intérêts variables
sava [ __ ] la marche est pas mon cas
journée de merde pour mafieux bord de
mer intéresse euros fanel faut la
remplacer la milf elle est périmée est
la vie entre temps c'est plus nul c'est
une grand mère maintenant ok alors la
chanteuse quoi entre sarah belli et
tiffany alors attends il aime quoi les
gens en ce moment il aime tout ce qui
est fictif à lévis avec totti fanny doit
faire de grandes choses ensemble tiffany
au moins de 1300 on est endetté jusqu'à
la mort j'avais pas vu ou des morts
allait le fils a fait des câbles bt
câble apprenait que doit à l'opa sur lui
trois pour montrer vos doigts c'est pas
grave je suis dans la merde je suis une
merde mafieux mon pote tu as échoué les
20 heures dans le jeu on a jusqu'à
demain il n'y a que quatre heures mais
morne steyn m avait plus en plus de tort
d'ailleurs dae soo des gens les gens ils
ont compris qu'elles d'arnac ce site un
temps il arrive d'y aller dentiste
réceptif pas face aux a fait faillite
alors met toi bien aux pas contre mende
aura plus de métier ça finit par métier
aux élections elle passe et tu es dans
le rouge depuis 24 heures honnêtement je
comprends pas trop comment tu as pu voir
et on s'est tous donné pour le bien de
ce projet est actuellement tout fait
foirer
ok bah écoute c'est pas la fin du monde
et c'est une nouvelle fois je suis sûr
que tu feras mieux comment ça s'est une
nouvelle fois à ça nous réconforte
l'assurance est vrai confort tu
commences à une nouvelle chanson s'est
endetté comme des paons auprès de la
banque les filles et un peu plus de moi
elles sont là je vous fumez 600 clubs l
on buvait un verre de whisky et ben
voilà on fera jamais un bon mafieux ont
pu la merde
bon soyons honnêtes on s'en bat les
styles quatre mauvais mafieux annonce
une prochaine draft avoir regardé portez
vous bien john numbi
oh